people of the internet retroreckons who
are here and i was so excited to see a
more complete tour of the gryffindor
common room than what we had gotten so
far as a gryffindor myself i had high
hopes for this common room and frankly
was not disappointed at the first look
but more so not very enthusiastic about
it i thought the other common rooms
outshined it a little bit well now that
we have gotten the full reveal i'm at
home guys i mean 100 gryffindor is my
house and this is the common room that i
would be most comfortable in there are
so many secrets so many fun little
details in a common room where it's
difficult to do that given how much we
already know about this common room
thanks to its prominence throughout the
series and one thing i want to say right
before we get started is there is a big
difference between the gryffindor common
room and all of the other three unless
i've just missed something which is
entirely possible given how many things
i have found in these videos after going
through multiple times i could still be
missing things but one of the most
surprising things about this one is that
i cannot find godric gryffindor himself
i cannot find him anywhere in the common
room unless they just have interpreted
him very differently and i'm not
realizing which one he is i mean salazar
slytherin is featured very prominently
in his house as is helga hufflepuff as
is rowena ravenclaw but gryffindor
nowhere to be found this one is much
more about house pride that kind of
school spirit vibe and i think it has
felt absolutely throughout this entire
common room if you guys find him let me
know the moment the gryffindor common
room tour begins you'll immediately
notice the house crest on the left side
and as the shot slowly pans over you'll
also see a banner featuring all four of
the hogwarts houses one thing that
immediately stands out in stark contrast
to the slytherin common room we covered
before is just the overall warmth of the
room you have these wooden beams across
the top that really help to break up the
stone whereas the slytherin common room
features the stone much more prominently
the red and gold of gryffindor is
instantly prominent across the tapestry
as are two more banners one featuring
just the house colors and another with
the house colors and another lion sigil
and for me the whole gryffindor common
room really gives off this vibe of an
old estate home on say a college campus
there's a strong sense of pride and
passion for wanting to show off their
house colors in sigil gryffindor common
room also places a focus on portraits
with many of these presumably being
former gryffindors again it all seems to
come back to that sort of school spirit
vibe of the house as the camera
continues to pan downward we'll see two
suits of armor flanking either side of
the entrance you'll also notice the
demiguise hiding in the tapestry right
here and then we start to get a look at
more of the furniture which features big
comfortable chairs more fabrics and lots
of dark wood there's a cabinet over here
on the right that appears to feature
some trophies and maybe even some house
awards but these are really hard to make
out again another banner here going back
to the school spirit once again and then
a portrait here above that's featured
very prominently but i don't believe
it's godric gryffindor also rugs lots
and lots of rugs this is clearly a
common room that places more of an
emphasis on being comfortable in the
next cut more of the same comfortable
chairs a very bold tapestry and yet
another house banner as well as another
hogwarts banner here the camera then
drops down low and gets ready to follow
the student into the next room there's a
big stone arched doorway here and then
some steps up into the next room a nice
little coat rack here on the right this
next room features two plaques on the
left side of the wall as well as a
portrait now this portrait actually
appears to match one from the room that
we were just in previously i really
enjoy this shot right here you get these
three large stained glass windows i mean
it really feels like you're in an
ancient cathedral or something the right
panel here featuring hogwarts the one in
the middle with the large g for
gryffindor and then the one on the left
featuring a quidditch player for
gryffindor don't forget the large
grandfather clock over here on the left
and i believe this right here is
actually a statue of a lion more
trophies and banners on the left now the
most interesting part for me these three
words right here underneath the g it
took me a little bit to get these
translated at first they weren't popping
up i was able to find the first two
under italian but not the third but now
i actually believe that all three of
them are latin and essentially this
phrase if you consider it all together
it means be strong and courageous this
would of course make sense for the house
of gryffindor the word forty meaning
strong animal meaning courage and estote
meaning to be be strong and courageous
and it's those little details like that
that i think are just going to make this
game truly truly shine we've seen it in
the slytherin common room now we're
seeing it here in the gryffindor common
room and in some ways i think the
gryffindor common room could have been
the most difficult because you consider
the fact that it is an iconic common
room i mean it's the one that we know
the best by far because that is what we
saw in the movies with harry ron and
hermione so they had to make a choice
you know do they make it something that
we're familiar with or do they go and
make something completely different or
do they try to find the happy medium and
given what chandler wood said about this
it certainly seems like they aired on
the side of staying true to what we know
but also adding a little bit that maybe
we didn't get in the movies but it's
actually going to be more book accurate
from the game and speaking of the
entrance that is the very next scene we
get we have the character here running
toward the portrait of the fat lady
again an iconic piece here we all know
how you get into the gryffindor common
room we've read about it we've seen it
in the movies you go up you give her the
password but before that though can we
just talk about this gryffindor robe man
these house fanatic robes i can't wait
these are so slick now for those of you
who have read the books see the movies
play the video games you'll know that
there have been a couple of different
variations in how this is handled in the
first and second harry potter movies
they actually had the entrance just like
it is here at the end of a quarter they
would then go on to change that for
prisoner of azkaban but the way that we
see it here is closer to how it's
described in the books the door swings
open forward and then reveals the hole
that the gryffindors have to crawl
through to get into the common room
again a feature that is more book
accurate then we get another shot inside
from a different perspective this time
in the windows here we've got to talk
about the windows this time because i
just love how much light they're letting
into this room i mean it just feels like
a warm cozy room it really does of all
the four common rooms this is the one i
mean it backs up why gryffindor is my
house i mean this is the one where i
want to spend the most time where i
would want to hang out for sure get a
closer look here at the suit of armor on
the left as well as the cabinet over
here with the trophies got a nice little
ottoman foot rest right here again this
common room it really seems like it is
all about the comfort with these big
squishy comfortable chairs and the nice
soft carpets about the floor all right i
can't quite make this out over here but
i do believe this might be a howler you
guys at first i thought maybe it was
like a really tiny owl but then i see
just this flash of red and then the
contrast with the white i'm almost
positive that is a howler then the
camera continues to pan over to the
right and we get a look at some self
shuffling cards and it's here in this
shot we get our first look at the
gryffindor fireplace which i'm pretty
sure is what we saw in that very opening
scene the camera was just positioned
right beside it so all we were able to
get a glimpse of was the crest at the
top now we can see here we have a large
stone fireplace here flanked by the two
lions on the left and right and then
above you have that very large
gryffindor crest this is awesome again
just so cozy is the word i keep coming
back to here i mean i could just see
this in my mind just imagine the snow
outside it's wintertime it's cold out
and you come in you just want to have a
seat right by the gryffindor fireplace
to get warm and then we also know that
years later this is the same fireplace
that harry is going to use to
communicate with sirius at times so i
really do love the look of the fireplace
here if we go a little bit to the left
of the fireplace though kind of right in
the center of our view here even more of
these really tall arched windows letting
lots of sunlight in another nice big
tapestry here even more little plaques
and achievements here above this large
archway and then just an h in the center
i'm assuming this one stands for
hogwarts doesn't have the full crest but
again that sense of school spirit is
really prominent throughout the entire
gryffindor common room now the
gryffindor tapestries in addition to
featuring all the different portraits
they were also known to feature
different animals we already pointed out
the dimmy guys and right here i think we
have what is clearly a phoenix pictured
let's talk about this here on the right
yet another suit of armor more portraits
more big cushy furniture there's
actually an animal skin rug here on the
right side and then we're going to see
this little white dot and then we get
the square button prompt so our
character stops gives a little spin
there and then look at this over here on
the left i'm not sure if it's
coincidence or not that it happens
immediately after they spin that but
once they do then we see a slightly
different indicator so this is not the
same circle icon this is a diamond icon
instead i think it's serving a very
similar purpose though i think it's
trying to show us hey this is something
you can interact with and i really want
to get a closer look through this glass
here on the left we see this kind of
blue and yellow box right here i don't
know if this is some sort of wizarding
world candy or maybe like a zonko's kind
of joke product and then just above it
what appears to be an animal could even
be a hippogriff dragon maybe i don't
know that one's pretty hard to see yet
another suit of armor all right this
very next shot here you have to slow it
down guys it happens quick because this
is by far the most talked about section
of the entire gryffindor common room and
sadly it really has nothing to do with
gryffindor's but it could have big
repercussions on the outlook for this
game and it is this chudley cannons
poster here on the left all right so if
you guys haven't heard about this yet
here's how it goes the chudley cannons
by the time harry potter and ron get to
school you know ron is a fan of the
chili cannons but they're known as being
a team that their glory days are behind
them but that hasn't always been the
case they actually used to be a really
good team and they won the entire league
a total of 21 times with the last
championship coming in
1892.
now this poster shows the chubby cannons
and then here at the bottom left
21. so what could this number 21 be
referring to now at the top this text is
really hard to read but i believe it
says we shall conquer but at the bottom
there is very clearly a21 so what is the
big deal about this well thanks to the
daily prophet shot that we got in the
other hogwarts legacy trailer we believe
that hogwarts legacy will start in
september of 1890 and assuming the world
cups here take place like they did in
harry potter's day just before the start
of the school year if this poster is
indicating that they have 21
championships then that would mean it
has to take place sometime after 1892.
we know the 1892 date thanks to
quidditch through the ages and 100 this
is something that they wanted us to
notice clearly they are trying to draw
our attention here even though it is
very brief now if that is the case that
it is in fact saying 21 championships
then this would almost confirm that
hogwarts legacy will take place over
more than one school year now me
personally i have said for a while that
i think the game will only be one school
year that's just been always the
tradition with harry potter anything
really books movies but for the most
part the stories of harry potter we
always think of them as being told over
a school year now this is not harry
potter this is something different this
is a new wizarding world tale and it is
an open world action rpg they could
absolutely span more than one school
year i just never imagined it in my
wildest dreams i really didn't and
honestly even after this i am still
not convinced i may have to make a whole
separate video on this you guys but
here's my thing with the poster here if
they were to have just won their 21st
championship don't you feel like it
would be a little bit more prominently
the words championship i mean i feel
like that would be the main focus right
it should say champion somewhere at the
top but instead it's kind of tucked away
down here in the bottom left corner
maybe it's just saying something like
they're chasing their 21st championship
so i certainly would not take this as
confirmation that hogwarts legacy is
going to be more than one year it could
absolutely just be in reference to hey
they're going after their 21st
championship or the number 21 could just
have been a bad choice maybe it's the
number of a player maybe it's the the
date of something that's happening
regarding the chubbly cannons like i
don't know maybe there's a meet and
greet on september the 21st or something
maybe they're going to be in hogs meet
on september the 21st maybe the 21 is
not in reference to the number of
championships now if i'm wrong on this
one i'm wrong and i will be super happy
to be wrong trust me because if this
game takes place over more than one year
well then i mean all the possibilities
just it goes crazy at that point right
if we're going into the third year we're
gonna see young dumbledore i mean it it
really goes absolutely insane at that
point however rain the expectations back
in i would certainly not take this as
confirmation that's all i'm saying we'll
keep an eye on it and see what else we
learn now in addition to everything else
though the fact that we have a shot of a
bulletin board here i talked about this
in the slytherin common room breakdown
does this mean we are going to get a
return of the lost items notice board
this was one of my favorite features in
the old school harry potter games you go
up you find something that someone has
posted on the notice board said hey i
lost this item i was around here if
anybody finds it please bring it back to
wherever maybe it goes in that little
chest that we found earlier we also have
another quidditch poster here a little
kind of pennant right here is the very
same stairs that we were going up
earlier in the video see there's the guy
again coughing getting a little choked
up over here on the right and this time
even though it's the same set of stairs
we get a slightly different look we can
kind of see a little bit more up here in
the top left corner more portraits and
more of the same when it comes to the
penance when it comes to the house pride
the hogwarts banners the red and gold
all displayed here and then we get a
nice overhead shot here of the common
room one sort of final pan of most
everything that we have seen already
throughout this trailer another look at
the shuffling card deck but then
something new in this one over here on
the left we catch the brief glimpse of
the golden snitch just there on the left
side of the screen now unfortunately if
you guys didn't see already quidditch
has been confirmed to not be playable in
hogwarts legacy but this makes the
second time that we have seen a snitch
like this flying around i could
definitely see that tying into some sort
of minigame or some sort of collectible
where we have to find it throughout
hogwarts now as a gryffindor myself i
absolutely love the gryffindor common
room but there are some amazing features
over in the slytherin common room as
well you can check that video out on the
left side of your screen now we got
ravenclaw up next once i have that video
ready it will be on the right side of
your screen as always thank you all so
much for watching i'll talk to you again
soon